The course that you're taking is
about native JavaScript promises.
They started showing up in
browsers around the end of 2014,
but polyfills for promises have been
around for much longer actually.
JQuery, which is obviously
a very popular library,
implements its own version of promises,
but they have some serious issues.
So I definitely recommend reading up
on them in the instructor notes if you
want to use them.
The first version of Angular
uses Q style promises.
These are mostly the same
as native promises, but
have some slight differences.
Angular 2,
however, will actually be taking
advantage of native JavaScript promises.
Once again, check the links in
the instructor notes to learn more.
As of this filming right now in December
of 2015, native promises are safe
to use with every major browser, except
for Internet Explorer and Opera Mini.
You'll need to make sure that
you include a polyfill or
some other kind of fall-back
on your production sites.
There are some new APIs that are also
taking advantage of promises.
For instance,
they're the recommended strategy for
interacting with the new
service worker API.
Service workers
are a total game changer.
They allow you to add a powerful
layer of control between your app and
the network, and that means that you can
actually create apps that work offline.
Seriously, it's amazing.
And you should check the instructor
notes to learn more.
In the next quiz you'll be using
another new API called the Fetch API.
It uses native promises to
simplify xml http requests.
That's really hard to say.
Substantially.
So let's go ahead and do it.